that was out in a way the girl that
always didn't quite get made it because
it was a unfinished script that you had
the languishing in your drawers 30 pages
of it and it wasn't until the ladies
were right here in America came along
that it got deaf again tell us about
what happened with that yeah
this way I'd be generating a lot of
different scripts and I can only bring
the first 30 pages of what would become
exactly but you know the rather rubbish
table Walker flats by really take
something but we suspect than that but
yes if we said retina farsighted
patients know pretty much as it is in
the film but I've got to the point where
I kind of say everyone off that Nick you
know I didn't really know where to take
it and married with dinner act and
traded in New York and she likes me to
say or something scripts or they were so
I wish you said everything every little
thing I had on my computer and she came
back I said what's this like flat script
I got malo about it so I can read it
again and I was like yeah I was ready at
that point to finish okay so glad that
happened
you know that's three and a half years
ago they were here shooting a film a
crazy Sumerian let's pick up your polity
at that at that point no you read those
30 pages little tease mindset God
touches and he was the rest with this
can you get it finished
what was it it really excited you about
the picture at that point I really
enjoyed the characters and I really
loved the world that they like them and
I really hated the boat and I wanted to
have it that world and I also just
really connected to the universal
emotion each character had and I also
enjoyed it as laughing Atlanta I got
what so and that's a good thing if you
get lost and I could come to you now now
I know that when you auditioned for
booked out you had a bit of an
interesting audition didn't you both in
terms of PC chose and in terms of
reception of one of the people who was
at the audition yeah well the people
that position that [ __ ] hallway
through it by the piece goes
okay voiceover from monster and Charlize
Theron voiceover and because I thought
she was oh she has a lot of things that
japanese character did yes my Chase
Utley said it's a boy that was so
compared to anybody else doing it well
oh how did you have to be feed about
your parents of Jacob what was it that
attracted you to that part to us no
controlling my heart intelligence that
but I think a little bit massively
serious it's just a nice character and
not that difficult to play I mean these
guys have a hard job you know not
speaking for an entire film is quite
tricky to make a good performance
whereas my character let's face it I got
easy easy but but you know it was a nice
script as bunch of people say why not
but you have to interact viewed some
link between the two different worlds
weren't you Jackson's world and a as
well as well yeah I mean it was it was
intimidating with with you know like
were they I mean I didn't have to do a
lot there because you know she I was
always feeding off her with McClair
stuff you know it was it was it was a
little trickier because there was you
know she was playing at their time yeah
but you don't think we got her in here
Jaclyn's
character is quite quiet Rathore wasn't
even had a lot of dialogue to work with
so maybe we play it is tell us a bit
about what you sort of did to prepare
yourself for that role and also the
challenges of playing a character that
doesn't have a lot of dialogue have to
communicate a lot through silence as far
as their character
Oh Joker thumb case and I was drawn to
Jacqueline that I've a reason that I
think about this very day like happening
you don't give you those moments there's
other moments just saying reflect and to
see what's happening and being
characters so the fact that she has
completely really terms accounts of the
challenge and as far as preparation he
goes I think preparing it differently
than why would from cats perhaps a lot a
lot of dialogue same way but because of
my character there was a lot research
number in your character courses so so
different that Jacqueline is not a li so
so different and I know you have some
interesting ways that you've had a
Gotland and her skin didn't use why
don't you tell us about them I had a lot
of fun and preparing for Italy because
she's not from character I entered a lot
of the behavior that she did that
it's a life drawing art classes and that
was fun I wanted to get the little
ghetto and part of me and I with the
week let me get along the obligation
interesting although it doesn't really
matter because she is having fun with
them Jacob in that scene where she goes
and takes Jacob to and some like joining
our class I'm rambling here and then no
and I also sketch deputy and that's when
I felt most like Ely when I just like a
diary use writing
everything would be able to sketch and
I'm not an artist so it was both fun and
you also didn't want anything to you
I've treated many other things and one
of the things I'm thinking of is that
you have thought about worksheet then I
got your video Brian for the people who
don't know here you don't have a
background in filmmaking and you just
something a little bit unusual with this
which is that you're at a computer
program on you and you do something a
lesser than the usual with this which is
that you didn't make a short film or
commercial or anything like that first
you actually went straight it died
straight into making a feature film why
did you decide to do that and how did
you find I experienced yes in some ways
it's like I kept saying that you know
when you know what the rules are meant
to me because then you don't kind of
follow them and you cannot run you know
you don't know how hard it is to make a
firm up front because you've never done
it before so you think well I can I can
do this and it's simply for not doing
short films I thought if you want to
make a professional sharp has been
taking liquor and you of your time I
thought well I'm gonna spend a year with
my time on something that rather do each
appellant
explosion affair Brian asked something
of Claire and mirin with their
characters which was not to talk or
interact offset during the production
and I wondered if you could say a little
bit about that and what it meant to you
when you're filming both in terms of
getting into character and in terms of
any awkwardness the boat cruises and
maybe Paro if you could say something as
well about what it was like being in the
middle being able to talk to these two
you two you actresses yeah it's really
difficult because we're running really
small
the locations very small like the rooms
are very small so we were always within
close proximity but a lot close
proximity to each other so it was it was
really difficult I suppose we just put
the shutters up and we could even be in
a car together at the same time and I
may throw more basic ways we just work a
wagon ships like this business we just
we didn't have any bond or connection
with each other and then my carrots I
think it really helped because the first
moment when we actually meet on the film
is actually deliver your tension it's
really that something that didn't really
help for that
and how did you find it do you find my
sure I love them immensely and stuff but
it was pretty pretty funny when they
proposed each other I'm just guys and
thanks straight face mystery mystery
buddy yeah good work so what else how
about you like for you hello agents
I think books I was so immersed and
aeleus world and I really believed in it
that I want the Kayle doesn't know who
Dracula it is she doesn't she doesn't
know who she is so it it just based on
my instincts and can await with my
instincts and it was what was needed and
I wanted to do the bit for brain spell
really I was that didn't work the way
you wanted it to you Brian
I guess thinks the reason I thought a
good idea was like anything you did to
help an actor have the right environment
for the characters it's kind of one of
the things you do that the rectum
it's gonna part it off whatever they
like you we we went to love the
direction and we can have made up laws
beforehand that they can we're friendly
and then I could say let's do this thing
so this happen what doesn't wanna be but
then I think going to simplest things
like the next box it
can only add some performance of hoping
it could necessarily take it away but it
was quite interesting the house when it
raced at lunch tables because we'd all
be taking the bugs and we can assess our
cooling the garage they were safe to fly
and basically whoever was a party to be
set with the rest a group another one
will be sitting on this little kids
phone so you can awake today wonderfully
talk a bit about the sheets itself and
any challenges upon cause we talked
about already or any happy man Siddhant
seeds have you found during that process
and if he wants to leave in first on
that question justice Jackson's well I
think that the French the French in that
which this do I did the French father
Mazzoni probably happy accident oh happy
for me not so much alone I was supposed
to know my life perfectly a French for
that that rivet missing it was and
unfortunately I failed to realize that
there was happening it turned out that I
completely failed a speaking French and
though actually it kind of worked out
all right I see and I thought with this
you know kind of looks like what Menace
meet you there
this is funny I was willing to see
boring that you're trying to direct to
see my little Frankie they're silly
you were saying the words their lips you
didn't even miss you tonight that's a
good sign shaking his head yes it may
the vaccine they asked me before hands
and how it's the water of the warm or
cold lovers as I have to thank her for
covering for Jacqueline where she's that
player needs to be cold so that mary has
called spite that problem however when
actually going water it was like the ice
had just melted it was the coldest thing
like everyone in my life and it's my
toes and I knew those they couldn't just
get out and could be taking us so long
to like the scenes so everything often
cost you everything there's no crack an
alibi what's up started spewing that it
was so painful for the sakes there cuz I
think it works it would be do again or
do you think
you